overwatch has had 12 maps since launch
but that number is about to jump to 13
I'm Tony and this is your objective
based game spot news update the new map
is called Ison Valda it's set in Germany
sporting a tall castle overlooking a
village the map takes a different
direction than previous ones as it's
much more vertical than usual around the
castle itself you'll even have to escort
the payload across a drawbridge
considering the German setting you might
think this map is rinehart's base of
operations but it's actually bastions
home turf his origin skin features a
forest look and this map shows off the
woods where he came from you'll be able
to explore the whole place when it goes
live in September since launch overwatch
has received a competitive mode a new
character and now this new map and
Blizzard has much more in the works
including more seasonal events like the
current summer games to keep up with
everything in the world of overwatch
stay grouped up with gamespot